[Music]  we are an unusual couple it was really  so fun getting to play all these  different decades throughout juan  division we just don't know what to  expect and then of course everything  kind of breaks down and becomes an mcu  version of the real world  am i dead no  why would you think that because you are  can't believe how it just keeps  unraveling and unfolding in ways that i  am still shocked and thrilled by  every day it's something different you  know it's high-tech marvel with  helicopters flying around and the next  day it's a perfect recreation of a 50s  sitcom you know some days it's it's both  i think something's wrong here  i think it's going to be really  satisfying for people when they realize  what is at the heart of this show this  is our home then let's fight for it  [Applause]  you